the heat capacity of an object is the
amount of heat necessary to raise the
temperature of the object
by one degree celsius or one kelvin
the specific heat capacity which is
often just called
specific heat is the heat capacity of
one gram of a substance
while the molar heat capacity is the
heat capacity for one
mole of a substance we symbolize
specific heat
with a capital c and a subscript s for
specific
and molar heat capacity is symbolized by
capital c
with a subscript m first let's look at
specific heat
the specific heat of water is equal to
4.18 joules per gram degrees celsius
and what this means is if we have one
gram
of liquid water and let's say the
initial temperature is 14.5
degrees celsius it takes positive
4.18 joules
of energy to increase the temperature of
that one gram
of water by one degree celsius
therefore the final temperature of the
water would be 15.5 degrees
celsius after we add 4.18
joules next let's calculate the molar
heat capacity of water from
the specific heat if we multiply the
specific heat of water
by the molar mass of of water which is
18.0
grams per mole
the grams will cancel out and that gives
us 75.2
joules per mole
degree celsius and so this is
the molar heat capacity of water
let's say we had 18.0 grams of water
if we divide by the molar mass of water
which is 18.0 grams per mole
the grams cancel and that gives us one
mole of liquid water so one mole
of h2o using the molar heat capacity
of water it would take positive
75.2 joules of
energy to increase the temperature of
that 18.0 grams of water by one
degree celsius next let's calculate
how much heat is necessary to warm 250
grams of water
from an initial temperature of 22
degrees celsius to a final temperature
of
98 degrees celsius using the units for
specific heat which are joules
per gram degree celsius we can rewrite
the specific heat is equal to joules
is the quantity of heat that's
transferred so we could just write
q for that grams is the mass of the
substance
and degree celsius is talking about the
change in temperature delta t
so if we multiply both sides by m delta
t
we arrive at the following equation
which is q
is equal to m c
delta t and we can use this equation to
calculate the heat
transferred for different substances
with different specific heats
however right now we're only interested
in our liquid water and how much heat it
takes to increase the temperature of our
water from 22 degrees celsius
to a final temperature of 98 degrees
celsius
to find the change in temperature that's
equal to the final temperature
minus the initial temperature which
would be
98 degrees celsius minus 22
which is equal to 76 degrees celsius
next we can plug everything into our
equation q
is what we're trying to find m is the
mass of the substance
which is 250 grams
c is the specific heat of water which is
4.18
joules per gram degree celsius and delta
t we've just found
is 76 degrees celsius so let's plug
everything into
our equation q would be equal to
the mass is 250 grams the
specific heat of water is 4.18
joules per gram degree
celsius and the change in temperature is
76
degrees celsius so looking at that we
can see that
grams will cancel out and degrees
celsius will cancel
out and give us q is equal to
79 420
joules or to two significant figures q
is equal to
7.9 times 10
to the 4th joules
so 7.9 times 10 to the fourth joules of
energy has to be
transferred to the water to increase the
temperature of the water
from 22 degrees celsius to 98 degrees
celsius the specific heat can vary
slightly with temperature so
temperature is often specified when
you're looking at a table for
specific heats for example in the left
column we have different substances
on the right column we have their
specific heats at 298 kelvin
so we could use for our units for
specific heat joules per
gram degree celsius or we could use
joules per gram kelvin for liquid water
the specific heat is 4.18 at 298
kelvin for aluminum solid aluminum
the specific heat is 0.90 and for
solid iron the specific heat is .45
joules per gram kelvin let's compare the
two metals
on our table here let's compare solid
aluminum and solid iron
so we're going to add 1.0 times 10
to the second joules of energy
to both metals and see what happens in
terms of change in
temperature first let's do the
calculation for aluminum
we're doing q is equal to mc delta t and
we're adding
1.0 times 10 to the second
joules and let's say
we had 10 grams of both of our metals
so this would be 10.0 grams of aluminum
and then we multiply that by the
specific heat of aluminum which is 0.90
so 0.90 joules per
gram kelvin times delta t
when we do the math for this the the
joules will cancel out the grams will
cancel out
and we would find that delta t would be
equal to
11 kelvin or 11 degrees celsius it
doesn't
really matter uh which units you're
using here for the specific heat
next let's do the same calculation for
iron
so we're adding the same amount of heat
so 1.0 times 10 to the second joules of
energy so we can plug that in 1.0
times 10 to the second joules we're
dealing with the same
mass so we have 10.0 grams of iron
but this time we're using the specific
heat of iron which is .45
joules per gram kelvin
times delta t so once again joules
cancels out grams cancels out
and we get that delta t is equal to
22 kelvin or 22
degrees celsius what we can learn from
doing these two calculations
is we had the same amount of heat added
to our
two substances with the mass of the two
substances was the same
the difference it was their specific
heat so
iron has a lower specific heat
than aluminum and since iron has a lower
specific
heat it's easier to change the
temperature of the iron so the lower the
value for the specific heat
the higher the change in the temperature
or you could also say the
the higher the value for the specific
heat the smaller the change
in the temperature and going back to our
chart
water liquid water has a relatively high
specific heat
which means the temperature of water is
relatively resistant
to change